Der Rasenfunk – Kurzpass. Wie ist die Liga in der spanischen La Liga verlaufen? Das wollen wir jetzt besprechen mit Alex Truica, freier Journalist, unter anderem Chefredakteur bei Barcawelt. Alex, sei mir sehr herzlich gegrüßt. Schön, dass du wieder mit dabei bist.
Max Servus, danke für die Einladung. Ich freue mich, wieder dein Gast zu sein.
Ja, sehr schön. Nachdem du ja schon mal bei uns über die La Liga gesprochen hast, wo du auch bewiesen hast, dass du trotz deiner Nähe zum FC Barcelona gut über alle Vereine reden kannst, das darfst du jetzt noch mal unter Beweis stellen.
Ich freue mich. Schauen wir mal.
Ja, das wird schon alles gut werden. Ich bin da sehr, sehr zuversichtlich. Die Ausgabe damals mit dir hat großen Spaß bereitet und es wird allerhöchste Zeit, dass wir wieder auf die Spanische Liga schauen. Denn sie ist jetzt zu Ende gespielt und da gibt es dann doch ein paar Themen, noch mal zu besprechen. Auch mit Blick auf das, was wir damals besprochen haben, ist da schon ein Weichen her. Angenehmerweise für dich als jemand, der dem FC Barcelona sehr nahe steht, starten wir auch die Tabelle beim spanischen Meister. Und wie in allen anderen vier europäischen Top-Ligen hat der Titel verteidigt werden können. In dem Fall vom FC Barcelona mit 11 Punkten Vorsprung, nur drei Niederlagen. Aber zur Geschichte dieser Saison gehört auch ein Champions League-Abschneiden, was ein Ausscheiden gegen den FC Liverpool im Halbfinale beinhaltete, nachdem man schon 3 zu 0 das Hinspiel gewonnen hat. Jetzt stelle ich dir die Frage, Alex, wie wird diese Saison von Barca bewertet? Auf der einen Seite diese absolut souveräne Meisterschaft und auf der anderen Seite dieses höchst unglückliche Ausscheiden im Champions League-Halbfinale.
Ja, tatsächlich wird ihnen ihre eigene Dominanz ein bisschen zum Verhängnis. Wie du schon sagst, sie dominieren zwar die Liga, aber sie scheitern krachend in der Champions League. Und das Problem ist, wenn du so dominant bist und immer wieder die Liga gewinnst, ich glaube, 8 der letzten 10 oder 11 Ligatitel haben sie gewonnen, diese Dominanz führt dazu, dass das Außergewöhnliche zur Normalität wird. Und das bedeutet, dass der Ligatitel immer weniger wertgeschätzt wird und der Fokus dann natürlich mehr auf die Champions League gelegt wird. Und wenn du da eben, wie ich schon sagte, dann krachend ausscheidest, ist das natürlich so ein Negativ-Ding, dass die Saison quasi nicht mehr so positiv wahrgenommen wird, obwohl du die Liga so dominiert hast, weil eben die Champions League alles überstrahlt heutzutage.
Ja, unglaublich eigentlich, wie dominant der FC Barcelona inzwischen einfach in La Liga ist. Das ist ja völlig richtig, was du sagst. Also man muss schon drei Jahre zurückgehen, da hat Real Madrid gewonnen. Dann muss man noch weitere drei Jahre zurückgehen, da hat Atletico gewonnen und dann nochmal zwei Jahre davor nochmal Real. Ansonsten immer der FC Barcelona von 2008 bis 2018. Das sind eben die zehn Meisterschaften, nur dreimal eine andere Mannschaft. Was hat sich denn da verschoben in Spanien? Kann man das noch auf den Stil von Barca reduzieren, der ja auch eine taktische Neuerung war? Was macht Barca so dominant?
Wenn du es reduzieren willst, muss man es tatsächlich auf Lionel Messi reduzieren. Es ist so simpel wie wahr. Es ist die Liga des Lionel Messi. Ich habe das selber so bei Barca geschrieben. Auch die spanischen Zeitungen haben das genauso geschrieben. Es ist seine Liga im doppelten Sinne. Er dominiert die Liga und er hat diese Liga fast schon eigenhändig gewonnen, also den diesjährigen Titel. Messi ist tatsächlich der alles überragende Spieler der Liga. Er dominiert jede Statistik. Obdach hat da eine schöne Statistik zusammengetragen, unter anderem von Squarger auf Twitter geteilt. Messi ist auf dem ersten Platz bei den Toren, bei den Assists, bei den Total Shots, also den Schüssen aufs Tor, Schüssen abgegeben aufs Tor, kreierten Chancen, kreierte Großchancen und so weiter und so fort. Also da gibt es noch einige mehr. Ich habe jetzt nur die bedeutendsten vorgelesen. 36 Saison-Tore sprüchen eine klare Sprache, 15 mehr als die zweitplatzierten Benzema und Suarez. Also du siehst, Messi ist der Dominator und das führt dazu, dass Barca so dominant ist.
Unglaublich. Im Grunde würde ich bei jedem anderen Spieler die Frage stellen, warum stellen sich darauf die Gegner nicht ein, aber weil es eben Lionel Messi ist. Es ist ja nicht so, dass das jetzt eine Neuigkeit wäre, aber er hat in der Saison wirklich noch mal dem Ganzen die Krone aufgesetzt. Du hast ja die 36 Tore schon genannt in 34 Spielen, die er gemacht hat, dazu noch 13 Assists. Und dass er wirklich so diese Liga dominiert, und das jetzt auch ohne den Antagonisten auf der anderen Seite, ohne Cristiano Ronaldo. Unglaublich. Und führt dann zu dieser dominanten Saison – ich habe es aber schon angesprochen – nur drei Niederlagen. Eine davon jetzt auch hinten raus noch. Was war das? Der 36. Spieltag gegen Zeltavigo. Genau, das war vor dem Auswärtsspiel dann beim FC Liverpool, als man noch dachte, man würde da locker weiterkommen. Ansonsten unglaublich dominant. Die erste, letzte Niederlage in der Liga davor. Da muss man schon bis zum 12. Spieltag gehen und ab dann immer gewonnen oder unentschieden gespielt. Stellt das denn die spanische Liga auch vor ein Problem?
Also grundsätzlich, wenn man über Barca spricht, muss man kurz auch den Trainer erwähnen. Das hat auch mit Ernesto Valverde zu tun, dass sie so dominant sind. Sie spielen jetzt anders, sie spielen pragmatischer, sie spielen sicherer, sie spielen weniger aufregend, aber sie sind sehr schwer zu schlagen, wie du die drei Niederlagen erwähnt hast. Teilweise in unwichtigen Spielen. Ich glaube, zwei davon kamen, als die Liga schon eingetütet war. Zumindest letztes Jahr war es ähnlich, da waren sie ja beinahe umgeschlagen gewesen. Da haben sie dann am vorletzten Spiel in Levante verloren. Da war die Liga auch schon gesichert und auch jetzt wieder. Sie sind unglaublich schwer zu schlagen, auch weil sie pragmatischer sind und weil sie vorne Messi haben. Sie sind aber auch weniger aufregend als zu den allerglorreichsten Zeiten. Das spielt so ein bisschen zusammen. Das führt dazu, warum sie so wenig Niederlagen haben. Aber vielleicht auch, um auf die Ausgangsfrage zu kommen, warum ihnen das Quäntchen in Europa fehlt, in der Champions League.
Interessante Situation. Auch wenn ich mich zurückerinnere, was wir damals im Kurzpass besprochen haben. Da haben wir vor allem auf die Unentschieden von Barca Bezug genommen. Die gibt es ja auch noch. Neunmal hat Barca tatsächlich nicht gewinnen können. Das schränkt diese Dominanz ein. Ich kann mich daran erinnern, dass wir damals darüber gesprochen haben, dass es ein bisschen ironisch ist, dass trotz dieser gar nicht perfekten Barca-Saison zum damaligen Zeitpunkt die Verfolger gar nicht wirklich Anschluss fassen können und Barca wirklich vor Probleme stellen können. Was uns ja dann auch zu Atletico bringt, die eben auf Platz 2 gelandet sind, aber eben mit diesen 11 Punkten Rückstand. Was hat denn da gefehlt bei Atletico? Hat man da vielleicht wirklich eine Chance liegen lassen, die Liga spannender zu machen, auch wenn es jetzt in der Endabrechnung sehr, sehr deutlich aussieht?
Also tatsächlich sind die Gegner Barcas nicht gut genug. Oder anders gesagt, Barca ist einfach besser als der komplette Rest. Der nicht nur Messi dominierte, auch Barca dominierte. Sie waren schlicht dieses Jahr die beste Mannschaft in Spanien. Die meisten Tore, die meisten Chancen, der höchste Ballbesitz, die meisten angekommenen Pässe. Sogar die meisten Alutreffer haben sie. Also sie dominieren jede Offensivstatistik. Und man kann da beispielsweise Real Madrid einen großen Vorwurf machen, Atletico kann man aber keinen Vorwurf machen. Die spielen tatsächlich einfach am Limit, die viel mehr ist für die nicht drin. Klar könnten sie das eine oder andere Unentschieden weniger haben. Also ich sehe jetzt gerade auf die Tabelle Atletico hat 10 Unentschieden. Das ist einfach zu viel, wenn du wirklich dann noch mal näher dran schnuppern willst an Barca. Das liegt aber auch einfach an Atletico selbst, am Stil, am Trainer, der ja immer sehr vorsichtig spielt, der besonders in großen Spielen immer wieder auf Konter setzt, auf eine dichte Defensive. Und das wird ihnen einfach zum Verhängnis, wenn sie manchmal gegen kleine Mannschaften spielen, wo ihnen dann einfach zu wenig einfällt, weil sie ja dann der Favorit sind und das Spiel aufziehen müssen. Und da häufen sich dann 1, 2, 3, 4 Unentschieden zu viel an oder vielleicht sogar eine Niederlage. Und deswegen reicht es nicht, warum sie an Barca nicht rankommen. Aber generell kann man Atletico kaum einen Vorwurf machen. Auch die spielen einfach am Limit und Barca ist einfach eine Nummer größer.
Atletico wieder mit der besten Abwehr der Liga, 29 Gegentreffer, aber eben nur in Anführungszeichen 55 Tore geschossen. Zum Vergleich, der FC Barcelona hat 90 Tore erzielt. Allein Messi und Suárez haben mehr Tore erzielt als Atletico insgesamt zusammengenommen. Jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, dass man bei Atletico die immer gleiche Schallplatte auflegt. Also ja, Atletico spielt einen defensiven Fußball. Ja, Atletico macht das sehr, sehr gut und ist immer nah dran. Aber es fehlt ein entscheidender Schritt, um nochmal nach vorne zu gehen. Und in dem Wissen, dass wir jetzt haben, dass Antoine Griezmann Atletico verlassen wird und damit auch einer derjenigen Faktoren, der dann vorne dafür gesorgt hat, dass wenn hinten die Null steht, wenigstens vorne die Eins-Minimum steht, stelle ich mir die Frage, wie groß ist der Druck auf Atletico, jetzt dann doch mal ein bisschen eine Entwicklung zu nehmen und vielleicht auch den eigenen Stil weiterzuentwickeln?
Ich glaube nicht, dass Simeone seinen Stil weiterentwickeln kann und auch will. Er setzt auf diesen Underdog-Fußball, diesen Arbeiter-Fußball, diesen defensive First-Fußball. Das wird sich nicht mehr ändern. Das ist sein Credo, das ist sein Stil, das ist wer er ist. Das überträgt er perfekt auf die Mannschaft. Aber vielmehr ist da einfach mit ihm, denke ich, nicht möglich. Klar, sie kaufen immer wieder aufregende Flügelstürmer vor allem oder Offensivspieler mit Lemar, mit Vitolo, jetzt Murata, Diego Costa, die kamen ja alle – Jelsen Martins kamen neu vor der Saison. Aber irgendwie funktionieren die in seinem Konzept nicht, passen nicht rein, passen nicht zu ihm. Und er geht dann immer wieder zurück zu seinem alten Stil, zu seinem Konterstil, zu seinem Defensiv-Pressing-Stil und sortiert dann quasi die frisch eingekauften Flügelspieler fast schon wieder aus. Also Jelsen Martins ist beispielsweise schon wieder bei Monaco, Vitolo spielt kaum eine Rolle, Lemar tut sich schwer. Also er hat kreative Spieler, aber irgendwie passt das nicht zu ihm, passen die Spieler nicht zu ihm und dadurch bleibt Atletico immer im gleichen Trott. Und ja, das hindert sich auch daran, quasi den nächsten Schritt zu machen. Das ist das eine und das andere ist, jetzt im Sommer wird eher ein Schritt zurückgemacht, weil sie ja die ganzen wichtigen Säulen verlieren. Grießmann ist vor dem Absprung, Just wahrscheinlich zu Barca, Gordin geht, der langjährige Kapitän, Juan Farran geht, Philippe Lui ist der Linksverteidiger, wird den Verein verlassen, Vertrag nicht verlängert. Also das ist da besteht, da ist ein großer Umbruch im Sommer, sprich Atletico wird eher schlechter als besser.
Das ist ja alles gut nachvollziehbar und ja auch für sich legitim. Dieser Stil von Atletico ist einzigartig und ja auch sehr erfolgreich. Also was kann man dafür, dass man mit einem FC Barcelona in der Liga spielt, der eben gerade Lionel Messi hat. Das ist jetzt aber meine sehr entspannte Sicht von außen auf Atletico. Ich muss mir ja auch nicht jedes Spiel von denen angucken, denn ehrlicherweise nicht jedes Spiel von denen ist wirklich schön anzugucken. Wie ist es, sieht es denn da im Umfeld aus und wie reagieren spanische Fußballfans auf die Entwicklung, die diese Liga genommen hat? Mit diesem klaren Meisterkandidaten Barca, dann dahinter normalerweise Real. Reden wir gleich darüber, warum nicht. Und eben Atletico als so das Ex-Negativo, also die eine spielen den tollen Offensivfußball, die anderen spielen den tollen Defensivfußball. Aber vielleicht guckt man das eine ja lieber als das andere.
Also grundsätzlich Atletico macht wirklich keiner einen Vorwurf, auch die breite Öffentlichkeit nicht, auch neutrale Fans nicht, die wissen Atletico steht, wofür es steht, der Trainer steht, wofür er steht und viel mehr geht da nicht. Und klar, man wünscht sich natürlich, die Medien wünschen sich, das sind neutrale Fans, klar, die wünschen sich einen spannenderen Titelkampf. Logischerweise ist ja in Deutschland auch so. Wir lächzen ja danach, dass es endlich mal spannend wird und wir waren ja froh, dass diesmal der Titel am letzten Spiel entschieden wurde. Aber niemand macht der Atletico wirklich einen Vorwurf. Jeder weiß mehr oder weniger am Limit. Klar, vielleicht könnten sie drei, vier, fünf Punkte näher an Barca dran sein, aber auf lange Sicht wird sich Barca, wenn alles normal läuft und wenn Messi sich nicht monalang verletzt, immer besser sein wird. Die Vorwürfe kann man an Ligo nicht machen, aber eben – und da kommen wir zum Verein, den wir jetzt besprechen werden – Real Madrid ist da das Thema. Also die müssten auf jeden Fall besser sein. Und da stürzt sich die öffentliche Kritik quasi drauf.
Dann lass doch mal über Real sprechen an der Stelle. Was ist da alles schiefgelaufen in dieser Saison, dass man nur in Anführungszeichen Dritter wird, mit 19 Punkten Rückstand auf Barca?
Ja, also aus Real Madrids Sicht war diese Saison wirklich ein großer Tiefschlag. Teilweise liest du da in den spanischen Gazetten von Schande, von Wörter wie Schande, peinlich, lauter solche beschreibenden Wörter. Die Spanier sind ja natürlich da nicht zimperlich.
12 Niederlagen, also unglaublich viel tatsächlich.
Ich glaube seit – ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher, müsste ich jetzt aus dem Kopf sagen, die Statistik – ich glaube seit 1996 waren sie nicht mehr so schlecht. Ich nagel mich nicht darauf fest auf die Jahreszahl, aber irgendwie in mehr als einer Dekade. Also so schlecht waren sie wirklich seit Ewigkeiten nicht mehr. 12 Niederlagen ist wirklich viel. Drei Trainer gab es ja, also sie starteten mit Lopetegui, dann kam Solari, jetzt ist wieder Zidane zurück. Also allein, klar, das kann ja nicht gut für eine Mannschaft und für einen Verein sein, wenn du da ständig den Trainer wechselst. Der Sprichbände, das zeigt, wie unzufrieden man im Verein ist. Also es war wirklich eine grausam, grausam schlechte Saison für Real Madrid. Das muss man einfach so sagen. Ja, da gibt es wirklich viele, viele Gründe dafür. Die müssen einfach einiges tun im Sommer.
Nenn mir mal die wichtigsten Gründe.
Also interessanterweise, als ich letztes Mal im Oktober, November bei dir zu Gast war, haben wir über Real Madrid auch schon gesprochen. Das erste Thema war der Abgang von Ronaldo. Und so abgedroschen, das klingt, man muss es einfach wieder nennen, weil das einfach ein Hauptgrund ist. Es gibt mehrere Hauptgründe, aber einer davon. Denn man darf nicht vergessen, einfach nur ein Blick auf die Tabelle zeigt, Barca hat rund 30 Tore mehr geschossen als Real Madrid. Und wer garantiert einem mindestens 30 Tore pro Saison? Eben jener Christiano Ronaldo. Also man kann es so leicht runterbrechen. Positiv für Real Madrid war Benzema. Er ist endlich aufgewacht, wenn man so will. Er war ja immer so im Dörrenröschenschlag. Während Ronaldo da war, hat er ihm als Zuarbeiter gedient und hatte dann immer für einen Mittelstürmer seiner Klasse viel zu wenig Tore. Der hat jetzt eben 21 Tore geschossen. Er hat einen Schritt nach vorne gemacht, aber der Rest der Mannschaft war viel zu schwach teilweise. Die Trainerwechsel sorgen dafür, dass dann immer wieder verschiedene Systemwechsel, verschiedene Spielertypen reinkamen. Isco saß mal zehn Spiele auf der Bank, dann spielte er wieder. Bale ist ein leidiges Thema, der dann immer wieder verletzt ist. Dann spielt er mal wieder mehr, dann unter sich, dann spielt er wieder weniger. Da kam immer wieder eins zum anderen. Generell ist die Mannschaft, das ist ein weiterer Hauptgrund, ist unglaublich, meiner Meinung nach, überaltert. Sprich, der Kern der Mannschaft ist einfach alt und satt. Das muss man einfach so sagen. Marcelo ist da ein Spieler, den man zuvor das nennen muss, der unter Lopetegui und unter Solari mehr oder minder sogar aussortiert wurde. Da hat dann Regulione, der Linksverteidiger, gegeben. Man darf nicht vergessen, Marcelo gilt ja eigentlich als bester Linksverteidiger der Welt, zumindest bis letzten Sommer. Und dann war da hinter allem 20-Jährigen nur noch der Backup. Das spricht Bände. Tazemiro hat eine schwache Saison gespielt. Toni Kroos hat eine sehr schwache Saison gespielt. Luca Modric hat man angesehen, dass er die WM durchgespielt hat bis zum Finale. Der war sehr ausgelaugt.
Also wirklich eine Saison zum Vergessen für Real. Man weiß gar nicht, welches Ergebnis man da rauspicken möchte. Man könnte mit dem Klassikoo noch im Oktober anfangen 1 zu 5 bei Barca verloren. Man könnte dann aber auch weitermachen mit dem Ausscheiden in der Champions League im Achtelfinale bei Ajax noch 2 zu 1 gewonnen und dann zu Hause dieses 1 zu 4. Davor hat man dann noch mal zweimal gegen Barca verloren im Copa del Rey Halbfinale mit 0 zu 3 zu Hause, dann im Klassikoo-Rückspiel der Liga mit 0 zu 1 zu Hause. Eine fürchterliche Saison und hat ja dann eben auch zu den von dir angesprochenen Trainerwechseln geführt. Ich glaube, auch den Real Madrid-Fans da draußen, wäre es jetzt am liebsten, wenn wir gar nicht jetzt noch mal drauf gucken, warum war das so schlimm. Es war einfach schlecht. Es war eine historisch schlechte Saison von Real, sondern den Blick nach vorne richten. Was glaubst du denn, wird sich jetzt verändern bei Real? Bisher war es ja meistens so, im Misserfolgsfall wurde die Schatulle geöffnet und dann so viele neue Qualitäten in den Kader geholt, dass man damit die Probleme beheben konnte.
Ich glaube, genau das wird sich verändern, nämlich der Kader. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass sie Hazard holen werden, dass sie sich auch schon einig sind mit ihm. Es wird auch spekuliert, dass Pogba kommen wird. Auch das ist, denke ich, sehr wahrscheinlich. Die haben ja Man United oder Champions League verpasst. Ich glaube nicht, dass er sich generell da wohlfühlt und jetzt ohne Champions League. Und falls Real wirklich anklopft, glaube ich, wird er das machen wollen. Also ich glaube, da wird sich was tun. Sie müssen auch was tun. Wie gesagt, der Kader ist überaltert. Bale muss gehen. Er hat ja das Bernabeu bei jedem Spiel ausgepfiffen. Der wird definitiv gehen. Wohin, weiß man noch nicht. Weil er verdient so viel Geld und hat zuletzt so schwankende, teilweise schlechte Leistung gezeigt, dass es schwer wird, dass ihn loswerden. Aber sie wollten ihn natürlich loswerden. Wenn sie da natürlich noch einmal Geld einnehmen können, würde ihnen das gut tun. Man darf nicht vergessen, Hazard und Pogba wären jeweils eine dreistellige Ablösekosten. Sprich, wenn du da 200 Millionen schon investierst, ist das teuer. Sie müssen auch ein bisschen was einnehmen. Viele Spieler sind unzufrieden und auf der Abschlussliste ist der Isco, Marcelo und so weiter einigenannte Spieler.
Es wird also weiter interessant sein, auf Real zu gucken. Jetzt kommen wir aber mal zu den Mannschaften, die nicht zu diesen natürlichen Dreien gehören, über die man immer spricht, wenn man über den spanischen Fußball spricht. Wir kommen zum FC Valencia. Der hat es geschafft, mit zwei Punkten Vorsprung, sich gegen den FC Retafel durchzusetzen und den letzten Champions League-Platz abzustauben. Valencia, die Unentschieden-Könige in La Liga, da haben wir auch schon häufiger in den spanischen Kurzpässen drüber gesprochen. Am Ende haben sie nur 15-mal gewonnen, 16-mal Unentschieden gespielt, aber eben auch nur 7-mal verloren. Das hat dann eben für 61 Punkte gereicht und für die Champions League-Qualifikation. Würdest du denn sagen, jetzt auch mit dem Saisonverlauf, es war gegen Ende hin tatsächlich sehr, sehr knapp zwischen Retafel und Valencia, haben die sich über die Saison hingesehen, verdient, in die Champions League zu kommen?
Eigentlich nicht, nein. Sie haben davon profitiert, dass die Verfolger eine schwache, durchwachsene, launische Saison hatten. Denn, man muss wissen, Valencia lag nur an zwei Spieltagen auf einem Champions League-Rang, am 37. Spieltag und am 38. Spieltag. Ansonsten waren sie konstant außerhalb der Champions League-Ränge. Da sieht man mal, wie glücklich das teilweise sogar ist, dass sie in der Champions League spielen werden, nächste Saison. Sie waren erst ab dem 29. Spieltag überhaupt in den Top 6. Und das hat ja schon einiges aus, nämlich ihr Saisonstart war eigentlich ziemlich katastrophal. Sie haben in den ersten 11 Spielen nur einen Sieg hinbekommen, bei aber auch nur einer Niederlage. Also, wie du schon richtig ansprichst, sie sind wirklich die unentschieden Könige, vor allem am Anfang der Saison gewesen. Aber durch einen wirklich starken Schlussspurt mit neun Siegen aus den letzten 13 Spielen haben sie eben am 37. und 38.
Da kann man dann am Ende natürlich sagen, gut, dann hat man es sich am Ende auch verdient, wenn man eben eine solche Serie startet. Der Saisonverlauf ist ja für alle egal, es zählt nur die Enderbrechnung. Was würdest du denn aber sagen, sind die Gründe dafür, dass sich Valencia eben so lange so schwer getan hat und es dann erst mit diesem Schlussspurt irgendwie geschafft hat, noch dieses Ziel der Champions League zu erreichen? Ich glaube, mich zu erinnern, dass wir immer über Offensivprobleme und fehlende Qualitäten im Sturm gesprochen haben bei Valencia.
Genau, tatsächlich war das ein Grund. Der Sturm war generell zu harmlos. Bezeichnet dafür ihr Top-Tor-Schütze mit neun Toren ist der zentrale Mittelfeldspieler Dani Parejo. Also das sagt ja schon alles. Sie haben keinen Spieler, der überhaupt zehn oder mehr Tore hatte. Ihre Stürmer haben viel zu wenig getroffen. Die haben auch sehr viel gewechselt. In der Hinrunde hat Batshuai noch bei ihnen gespielt, hat aber nur ein Tor in elf Spielen, glaube ich, geschossen. Jetzt ist er bei Crystal Palace. Ab und zu hat Gamiro gespielt, der ja von Atletico kam, war aber hauptsächlich auch Edeljoker. Gedes, der portugiesische Flügelspieler, kam überhaupt nicht zum Tragen. Jetzt am Ende hat er, glaube ich, fünf Tore insgesamt geschossen. Also die Offensive war da zu schwach. Aber was Valencia gut gemacht hat, ist, sie haben an ihrem Trainer festgehalten. Marcelino wackelte ja gewaltig am Anfang bzw. bis zur Mitte der Saison. Doch sie haben ihn festgehalten und es sollte sie auch sein. Sie haben sich stabilisiert und am Ende tatsächlich gerade noch so die Champions League gebracht, was ja enorm wichtig ist für Valencia. Und ja, das war so der Hauptgrund, würde ich sagen. Viele Mannschaften – und wir werden ja auch auf einige andere Mannschaften noch zu sprechen kommen – würden da normalerweise den Trainer wechseln, weil sie ja beispielsweise – lass mal kurz nachschauen – im 19.
Und man hat ja auch noch das Copa del Rey-Finale, zwar gegen den FC Barcelona, also es ist ein dickes Brett, was man da bohren müsste, aber eventuell kann sich Valencia dann sogar diese dann hinten raus erfolgreiche Saison noch weiter veredeln. Was uns dann ja aber auch zu einer der Mannschaften bringt, die es eben knapp nicht geschafft haben. Und der FC Retafel, den habe ich schon angesprochen, der war eben bis kurz vor Schluss im Rennen um die Champions League. Da habe ich erstmal die Augenbrauen gehoben und habe mir gedacht, oh, da muss ich wieder einen La Liga-Kurzpass machen, denn die hatte ich nicht so auf dem Zettel. Liegt das jetzt an mir oder am FC Retafel?
Das liegt am FC Retafel und am Trainer. Tatsächlich ist es die beste Saisonplatzierung in der Club-Historie. Sie sind fünfter geworden, wären um ein Haar sogar vierter geworden, wenn ich Valencia am Ende diesen Schlussspurt hingelegt hätte. Tatsächlich ist Getafe ein unglaublicher Underdog, der überperformt hat. Niemand hätte das erwartet, dass sie so gut sind. Interessant ist, ich habe noch Ranking gefunden. Vom Budget her sind sie Vierzentern in La Liga und sie sind Fünfter geworden. Sie sind neun Plätze besser gelandet als ihr Budget. Sie sind also das Überraschungsteam der Saison. Wenn man es vergleichen will, ist der FC Getafe der FC Schalke Spaniens. Zumindest der FC Schalke der letzten Saison, nicht der diesjährigen Saison, nämlich der FC Schalke, der Vizemeister wurde. Sie stehen hinten unglaublich sicher, sie sind kompakt, sie sind bissig, unbequem zu spielen, unglaublich zweikampfstark und so einfach sehr, sehr schwer zu schlagen. Sie haben sich konstant immer wieder oben gehalten. Man muss sagen, sie waren so unkonstand Valencia, durch den Schlussspurt, so konstant, aber Getafe haben sie durchgängig die gesamte Saison über da oben gehalten. Ich glaube, in der Hinrunde waren sie Fünfte und in der Rückrundentabelle sind sie Sechste.
Ja, und wer sind da so die Spieler, die man hervorheben kann? Oder muss man den Trainer als allererstes nennen? Woher kommt jetzt diese sehr erfolgreiche Saison?
Also tatsächlich ist der Trainer zu nennen für mich auch der Trainer der Saison. Pepe Bordalas hat eine klasse Mannschaft geformt, die wirklich als Einheit spielt. Für viele ist Bordalas der Trainer der Saison aufgrund dessen, was sie erreicht haben, aber nicht aufgrund seines Fußballs. Also die Spanier mögen ja normalerweise auch, abgesehen von Atletico, denen sieht man es nach. Aber normalerweise will man ja schön Kurzpass-Fußball sehen. Kriegst du bei Getafe überhaupt nicht, wie gesagt, der Vizemeister Schalke, wenn man so will. Sie haben fünf Uruguayer im Kader und die verkörpern so ein bisschen den Spielstil. Sie treten quasi mit so einer Karacharua auf, also dieser typisch uruguayische Kampfeswille, diese Widerstandskraft, diese Hartenklichkeit. Und so spielen sie auch. Man muss sagen, ein Beispiel ist stellvertretend der zentrale Mittelfeldspieler Mauro Arambari, der wirklich ein Uruguayer ist und eben dieses kämpferische Element mit reinbringt, diese Wille, diese Kampfeskraft. Sie sind nicht schön anzuschauen, wie gesagt. Sie bezeichnen den – und das ist wirklich interessant – den wenigsten Ballbesitz der gesamten Liga mit 43 Prozent und die schlechteste Passquote der Liga mit 63 Prozent. Und doch wurden sie fünfter. Da gab es eine spanische Journalistin, die den schönen und treffenden Satz gesagt hat, in Getafe zu spielen ist wie zum Zahnarzt zu gehen. Und tatsächlich so kann man es wirklich zusammenfassen. Aber als Team haben sie sich das wirklich verdient.
Und sie langen auch gerne mal hin. Also 104 gelbe Karten, sieben Platz verweilen. Es gab zwar noch Mannschaften mit mehr gelben Karten. Also Atletik Bebar 117 gelbe Karten. Und für die Zeitreise, meine Güte, der abso schöne spanische Fußball. Da gibt es aber auch eine Schattenseite, die nicht auf meinem Radar war. Aber das kommt bei Getafe sicherlich auch noch mit dazu. Wir wollen das jetzt aber nicht alles schwarz machen. Es ist ja wirklich eine beeindruckende Leistung. Und das muss man erst mal schaffen, sich durchzusetzen gegen Teams wie ja zum Beispiel auch den FC Sevilla, der jetzt einen Rang dahinter gelandet ist. Die hätte ich jetzt eher rund um die Champions League Plätze vermutet. Es waren am Ende zwei Punkte, die gefehlt haben. Wie ist die Saison vom FC Sevilla einzuordnen?
Tatsächlich war Sevilla zu inkonstant und zu launisch, um am Ende an der Champions League anzuklopfen. Also sie haben die Champions League auch verdient verpasst, muss man so sagen. So ein klein bisschen, wenn wir schon bei Vergleichen sind, Schalke und Getafe kann man sagen. Sevilla ist so ein bisschen das Glattbach Spanien. Sie haben eine super Hinrunde gespielt, mit nur drei Niederländen in 18 Spielen. Aber in der Rückrunde ist irgendetwas Unerklärliches passiert, denn in der Hinrunde waren sie auf Kurs Champions League, doch dann ging es bergab. Zwischen dem 14. und dem 26. Spieltag haben sie nur zwei Siege einfahren können. Da haben sie wirklich, also für mich auch unerklärlich, warum sie da so abgestürzt sind, warum sie da ihren Mojo verloren haben. In der Zeit haben sie dann auch ihren Trainer entlassen. Da haben wir es wieder, dass die Spanier dann normalerweise gerne den Trainer entlassen, wenn es dann über 10, 15 Spiele nicht klappt. Genau, in dieser Siglos-Phase haben sie Pablo Machín entlassen, auch als er – oder besonders – als er mit Sevilla im Achtelfinale völlig überraschend an Slavia-Park scheiterte, da haben sie ihn gefeuert und der alte Fahnsmann Joaquín Caparossa dann übernommen, der zuvor Sportdirektor war, der hat sie dann quasi stabilisiert, aber diese Siglos-Serie hat im Endeffekt dann die Teilnahme in der Champions League gekostet. Auch ein Grund war, auch am Ende wieder haben sie in den letzten sechs Spielen, also Spieltag 33 bis 38, haben sie nur zwei Siege angefahren und dann hat es einfach nicht gereicht. Sie waren zu unkonstant, sie waren zu launisch, sie waren vor allem auswärtsschwach, chronisch auswärtsschwach, muss man sagen. Sevilla hat schon letztes Jahr wirklich grausame Auswärtsspieler hingelegt und eine schreckliche Auswärtsbilanz gehabt. Und auch dieses Mal waren sie wieder nicht gut genug. Denn von ihrem – Time-Stall ist Sevilla traditionell – aber von ihren Insaisont 13 Saisonwiederlagen gab es neun in der Fremde.
Genau, diese Niederlagen da am Schluss, das begann eben mit einem Auswärts 0-3 beim FC Retafel, der damit auch so ein bisschen den Schlusssport einleiten konnte, der eben fast wieder auf dem Champions League-Platz geändert hätte, dann noch verloren bei Girona gegen Leganes zu Hause. Das war sehr, sehr schlaff mit 0-3, gegen Atletico 1-1 noch völlig okay, aber so dann eben der sechste Tabellenplatz und damit die Europa League, das passt ja wiederum ganz gut zum FC Sevilla ab. Das würde ja doch ganz gerne irgendwann auch mal ein bisschen sich weiterentwickeln. Auf Platz 7 gelandet ist dann Espanyol, die haben sich aufgrund der besseren Tordifferenz und zwar der um zwei Tore weniger schlechten Tordifferenz auf den siebten Platz noch schieben können. Sie haben eine Tordifferenz von minus zwei und dahinter liegt mit Atletik Bilbao eine Mannschaft, die eben dann wegen des Tordifferenz-Ergebnisses von minus vier trotz der gleichen Punktzahl 53 Punkten eben nicht international spielen darf. Ich habe gerade schon bei Atletik die Statistik rausgesucht, die mir am meisten aufgefallen ist, nämlich diese 117 gelben Karten und die fünf roten. Jetzt wollen wir aber auch noch über das Sportliche reden und nicht nur auf das Verhindern des Sportlichens. Was war das für eine Saison für Atletik Bilbao?
Da muss ich kurz dazwischen reden. In Spanien bei Punktgleichheit gilt der direkte Vergleich.
Ach ja, stimmt, richtig. Mensch, das wusste ich doch noch wegen Krätafel, weil die gegen Valencia, ja, okay.
Genau, genau. Deswegen ist Espanol nicht wegen der Tordifferenz in Europa, aber auch wenn auch die den Ausschluss für Espanol positiv werden würden, aber es war tatsächlich der direkte Vergleich. Aber das ist spannend. Für Espanol ist das ein Riesenergebnis, die Euroleague erreicht zu haben, denn sie haben seit zwölf Jahren nicht mehr in Europa gespielt. Da gab es auch einen Platzsturm, was man in Spanien sehr selten sieht, eigentlich nur bei Aufsteigern so richtig. Da sieht man mal, wie sehr dieser Verein nach Europa gelext hat, was für den Verein und die Fans das bedeutet. Dieser Platzsturm war tatsächlich bezeichnend. Für Espanols Glück ist Athletic Bilbao's Pech, denn sie scheiterten tatsächlich auf aller dramatischste Weise in der letzten Sekunde. Sie haben in Sevilla gespielt. Am letzten Spieltag brauchten sie nur einen Punkt, um die Europa zu erreichen, um dann einen Punkt vor Espanol zu liegen. In der 91. Lagen sie 0-1 hinten, hatten eine eigene Ecke. Und dann traf Bilbao nach dieser Ecke die Latte. Und im Gegenzug gab es den Konter zum 0-2.
Und jetzt, abgesehen von diesem dramatischen Finale, ist das jetzt eine besondere Saison für Bilbao dennoch gewesen, dass man so nah dran war? Die Zahlen lesen sich so unspektakulär, dass ich das von außen nicht deuten kann. Also 13 Siege, 14 Unentschieden, 11 Niederlagen, 41 erzielte Tore, 45 kassierte Tore. Das hört sich nach einer guten Durchschnittsmannschaft an, die bei einem guten Saisonverlauf der Konkurrenz dann irgendwie doch oben mit reinrutscht. Trifft denn diese Einschätzung von mir zu oder ignore ich damit klar ersichtliche Fakten, so wie ich ja hätte wissen müssen, dass die Direkte verkriegt?
Du ignorierst den Saisonverlauf tatsächlich. Es ist nämlich so, sie hatten wie Valencia auch eine fürchterliche Hinrunde, haben den auf Wand tatsächlich sogar in Abstiegsnöten. Bis zum am 17. Spieltag, also ziemlich genau die Hälfte der Saison, lagen sie auf dem 16. Platz, auf dem Abstiegsplatz, haben dann ihren Trainer entlassen, Eduardo Berriso, unter dem es gar nicht lief, also sie sind überhaupt nicht mit ihrem Trainer zurechtgekommen, haben dann Gajska Garitano geholt, der Coach des B-Teams, wurde dann befördert und unter ihm gab es dann einen Aufschwung. In der Rückrunde haben sie wirklich eine Auffalljagd gestartet, so ein bisschen Valencia-like, wenn man so will. In den 24 Spielen unter Garitano haben sie 12 Siege, 6 Unentschieden, 6 Niederlagen eingeheimst, also eine sehr passable, gute Bilanz und es hätte eben, wie gesagt, fast bis nach Europa gereicht, wenn eben die 91. Minute und dieser Lappentreffer nicht gewesen wäre. Aber im Endeffekt muss man sagen, die erste Hälfte der Saison, da waren sie zu schwach, sprich, man kann sagen, es wäre auch nicht verdient gewesen, weil, wie gesagt, am 17. Spieltag noch am Abstiegskampf zu stecken und am Abstiegsrang festzukleben, zeigt eigentlich, dass sie wirklich keine gute Saison gespielt haben.
Und dann haben wir, wenn wir weiter nach hinten gehen, hast du mir gesagt, du würdest mit mir noch gerne über Real Betis sprechen. Die sind jetzt auf Tabellenplatz 10 gelandet mit 50 Punkten. Punktgleich mit Real Sociedad und Deportivo a la Vez. Das ist so die Dreierreihe Platz 9, 10, 11. Was hebt denn für dich Betis aus diesen Mannschaften hervor? Warum sollen wir die jetzt hier besprechen?
Warum sollen wir die besprechen? Das ist dann 110. Tatsächlich, weil es mit das Interessanteste Team Spaniens ist, weil sie eben so einen besonderen Fußball spielen, so ein bisschen Pep-Fußball, wenn du so willst, also Ballbesitz wird groß geschrieben. Kike Setien ist bekannt dafür, quasi sozusagen Cruyffista zu sein, also ein Fußballpurist, der im Stil der Johann Cruyffs Ballbesitzfußball predigt, das ist sein Credo. Er will, dass seine Mannschaft eben im Pep Guardiola-Stil wirklich schön anzuschauen und Fußball spielt. Aber sie konnten das irgendwie nicht in zählbares ummünzen, also sie haben tatsächlich unterperformt, wenn man so will. Und was für Ampethis auch interessant ist, sie sind das einzige Team, das in der Saison Barca, Atletico und Real Madrid schlagen konnte. Also ein richtig, richtig besonderes Achievement. Aber das Problem von Betis waren die Leistung gegen die kleinen Teams. Irgendwie haben sie sich gegen die kleinen Teams unglaublich schwer getan. Ihr schöner Ballbesitzfußball wurde oft zu leeren Ballbesitzfußball, zu fruchtlosem Ballbesitz, wenn man so will. Da konnten sie dann irgendwie ihre Überlebenheit viel zu selten in Tore oder auch in Chancen ummünzen und in Siege logischerweise.
Stimmt, das war auch damals dein Tipp, dass man sich, wenn man La Liga anguckt, sich Real Betis anguckt. Jetzt ist ja aber genau Jena Kike Setien entlassen worden. Er ist nicht mehr bei Real. Wie ist das jetzt einzuschätzen? Auf der einen Seite hat sich ganz viel von dem, was du gesagt hast, ganz toll angehört. Und auch die Statistiken, also Real Betis hatte noch mehr Ballbesitz durchschnittlich in dieser Saison als das große Real. Also sie liegen auf Platz 2 hinter Barca und sie haben auch eine sehr, sehr gute Passquote. Wie beurteilst du diese Trainerentlassung? Sie aus der Ferne betrachtet, ergibt die dann ja gar nicht so viel Sinn. Was freht mir da?
Ja, also ist tatsächlich komplex. Ich habe ja den fruchtlosen Ballbesitz angesprochen. Da gab es zwei krachende Niederlagen. 04 in Levante, 03 in Leganes. Die natürlich klar verlieren immer unschön, aber dann bei so – ja, bei Underdogs, bei grauen Mäusen wie Levante und Levanes dann so krachend zu verlieren, wird eben nicht gut aufgenommen. Das Interessante ist, Betis hatte beim 04 in Levante, ich sage und schreibe, 61 Prozent Ballbesitz und beim 03 in Leganes 68 Prozent Ballbesitz, aber nur drei Torschüsse. Also du siehst, dieser flottlose Ballbesitz wurde es setieren, irgendwo auch zum Verhängnis. Ein Problem war, sie hatten keinen Knipser, sie haben nur 44 Tore geschossen in 38 Spielen, das ist einfach viel zu wenig für eine Mannschaft mit Europaambition. Sie haben gleichzeitig aber 52 Gegentore kassiert, das ist dann wieder zu viel. Also du siehst Ballbesitz nur als Selbstzweck. Auch in Spanien, das immer so ein bisschen den Ballbesitz liebt, müssen Ergebnisse folgen, die kamen leider nicht. Und um auf die Träne entlassen und dann zu sprechen, er wurde auch wegen der Erwartungshaltung entlassen, denn er sagte etwas Interessantes. Letztes Jahr haben sie Europa erreicht und Zedjén meinte in einem Interview, dass dieser Schritt zu früh kam quasi und dass dann eben die Erwartungen anstiegen und nun das Verpacknissen Europas wurde ihm halt zum Verhängnis, weil es quasi als zu wenig angesehen wird. Und man muss aber auch sagen, unterm Strich ist es auch eine schwache Saison. Mit diesem Kader hätte mehr drin sein müssen. Sie haben einen richtig, richtig starken Kader mit richtig interessanten Spielern. Vor allem im Mittelfeld, wenn man da Sergio Canales nennt, beispielsweise, sie haben Hintmar Batra, den kennt man ja aus der Bundesliga, das ist eigentlich auch ein recht klangvoller Name, wenn man so will. Sie haben noch wirklich gute Spieler, William Carayo, den Portugiesen, Uadado, der Mittelfeld-Zerstörer, Mexikaner. Also mit dieser Mannschaft müsste mehr drin sein als von 10. Und irgendwie haben sie es, wie gesagt, trotz viel Ballbesitz, vor dem der Knipser gefiel, die Ergebnisse nicht eingefahren. Und das wurde seitdem zum Verhängnis, weil die Andalusier sehr heißblütig sind. Also in Sevilla, wie auch beim rivalen FC Sevilla, wo ja Marquín entlassen wurde, wie ich gesagt habe. Wenn da die Resultate nicht stimmen, verliert man gerne mal die Ruhe und dann wird er drin entlassen. Ob das die richtige Wahl ist, muss man abwarten. Könnte man jetzt stundenlang diskutieren, muss man eigentlich sagen.
Das wird die Zukunft zeigen müssen, wie so häufig. Also Real Betis vielleicht erinnert sich auch noch die eine oder andere Hörerin und der eine oder andere Hörer. In der Europa League Zwischenrunde gegen Stadt rennen, auswärts noch 3 zu 3 gespielt, dann zu Hause 1 zu 3 verloren. Da hat man eigentlich viel von dem gesehen, was du jetzt auch beschrieben hast. Sowohl das Gute als auch das Erfolglose und etwas Fruchtlose. Die Partien habe ich auch so mit einem Auge mitverfolgt. Das war die Saison bei Real Betis. Ansonsten möchtest du noch gerne über Villarreal sprechen. Die sind auf Tabellenplatz 14 rausgekommen mit 44 Punkten und hatten, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, jetzt nicht die sorgenfreiste Saison ihrer Geschichte. Was war da los bei Villarreal?
Tatsächlich spielte auch Villarreal völlig überraschend. Sehr lange gingen die Abstiegkampfs. Mit Achungkracht den Abstieg vermieden. Jetzt hinten raus sieht es gut aus mit 44 Punkten, wohingegen Girona 37 hatte. Aber das war tatsächlich bis vor zwei Spieltagen, bis zum 35. oder 36. war das ein unglaublich schnappes Rennen. Also bei Villarreal zitterte man sehr. War die Negativ-Überraschung, wenn man so will, mit Celta Vigo der Saison. Aber tatsächlich Villarreal ist ja eigentlich ein Team, das man immer in Europa erwartet und die eigentlich jedes Jahr die Europa League erreicht. Und auch immer eine gute Rolle spielt. Die haben ja auch gerne mal Leverkusen rausgeworfen, kann ich mich erinnern. Also das war so die Negativ-Überraschung, wenn man so will, Villarreal. Auch da viele Unentschieden. 14 Unentschieden ist halt einfach immer ein bisschen viel. Da verlierst du lieber zwei Spiele davon mehr und dafür gewinnst du mehr. Die Unentschieden sind halt dann einfach nicht gut auf lange Sicht. Und auch da zu wenig Tore geschossen, muss man sagen. Das wohl ein verhängendes Trainerwechsel. So kam eins zum anderen. Verletzungen, also so eine typische schlechte Saison, wie es halt manchmal gute Teams drin haben, wo halt eins zum anderen kommt.
Ja und mit dieser interessanten Dynamik, die man ja auch häufiger bei solchen Teams hat. Der Saisonstart läuft überhaupt nicht gut, du hängst unten drin. Aber dann gibt es diesen einen Wettbewerb, bei dem du immer noch mal völlig anders auftrittst als in der Liga. Das war eben bei Villarreal die Europa League. Da sind sie durchgerauscht, ist fast ein bisschen zu viel. Aber ohne Niederlage sind sie bis ins Viertelfinale eingezogen, haben Gegner wie die Glasgow Rangers, Spartak Moskau, Rabet Wien, Sporting Lissabon und Zenit St. Petersburg besiegt und gerade dieses Achtelfinale gegen Zenit auswärts 3 zu 1 gewonnen, zu Hause 2 zu 1. Das war sehr, sehr konstant. Erst dann im Viertelfinale gegen den FC Valencia gab es dann die ersten beiden Niederlagen in diesem Wettbewerb. Und eben wieder so ein klassisches Beispiel für eine Mannschaft, die in einem Wettbewerb unglaubliche Probleme hat, dagegen den Abstieg kämpft. Es funktioniert gar nichts. Und zwischendurch kommen dann immer wieder Europa League Spiele und die wirken dann wie eine Befreiung. Und man kriegt dann diese beiden verschiedenen Mannschaften gar nicht so übereinander. Aber das hat man ja auch häufig genug auch schon in der Bundesliga erlebt.
Ja, ganz komisch. Wahrscheinlich können die das dem Verein selber nicht erklären. Warum sie dann in der Liga kaum ein Bein bis mehr oder weniger 35. Spieltag auf dem Boden kriegen. Und in der Europa League spielen sie halt frei auf. Ich würde sagen, Psychologie ist eine seltsame Sache.
Da würde ich dir zustimmen. Und mit Psychologie sind wir dann irgendwie ja auch schon bei Celta Vigo gelandet. Die hast du gerade auch schon mitgenannt als eine der größten Enttäuschungen. Diese Saison haben einen völlig irren Saisonverlauf. Zwischenzeitlich allerdings nur sehr kurz, dritter, vierter Spieltag, waren wir mal auf Rang 3. Und dann begann ein langer Absturz, der dann auf den Abstiegsrängen endete am 21. Spieltag. Und ab dann wurde es ein Gewürge ohne Ende. Und man hat es am Ende irgendwie noch geschafft, mit einer Serie aus den letzten sechs Spielen, mit nur einer Niederlage, sich dann vor dem Abstieg zu retten. Auf dem 17. Tabellenplatz ist man gelandet. Vier Punkte Vorsprung hatte man dann am Schluss auf den Abstiegsrang. Was sind die Gründe dafür, dass es bei Celta so eine fürchterliche Saison wurde?
Tatsächlich eine typische Chaos-Saison, wie man sie immer mal wieder erlebt bei Mannschaften, bei denen man das nicht erwartet. Trainerwechsel, je mehr, desto schlechter. Das ist eine einfache Rechnung. Sie hatten drei verschiedene Trainer in der Saison. Sie begannen mit Antonio Mohamed, der wurde am 12. Spieltag entlassen. Dann kam Miguel Cardoso, der wurde am 26. Spieltag entlassen. Dann kam der dritte Trainer, Fran Escriva, der hat sie gerade noch so gerettet. Unter dem waren die Ergebnisse tatsächlich gut bis passabel. Unter den vorherigen beiden Trainern stimmte einfach gar nichts. Es ist manchmal wirklich schwierig zu erklären, wenn es in einem Verein drunter und drüber geht, woran es dann genau liegt. Sie werden tatsächlich beinahe abgestiegen und es wäre irgendwo, muss man auch sagen, fertig gewesen, wenn sie abgestiegen wären. Denn auch Celta Vigo hat eigentlich immer so ein bisschen Europaambition. Also so Platz 5 bis 9 wäre ihr natürliches Habitat. Und das jetzt mit 8 und krachsitzender werden, einen Rang vor den Abstiegsrängen, sprich Bände. Sie hatten einen Retter, also auf niemanden kann man das besser zuschneiden als auf Iago Aspas. Das war wirklich der personifizierte Retter Celta Vigos. Er ist eh schon vereint, sie kohle, er ist ihr Stürmerstar, er ist schon als Jugendlicher in einem Verein gespielt, er ist in Galizien geboren und hat tatsächlich, das war eine Ein-Mann-Rettungsmission. Das Interessante ist, ich glaube er hat 20 Saison-Tore geschossen, in nur 26 Spielen, also richtig, richtig krasse, krasse Tor. Tor-Statistik, pardon, genau. 21 Tore waren sogar, nicht 20 sehe ich gerade, 21. Und das Interessante ist, als er verletzt war, er hat nämlich mit einer Wadenverletzung ich glaube 9 Spiele verpasst und von diesen 9 Spielen hat Celta dann 8 verloren ohne ihn. Also richtig krass, wie abhängig Celta von ihm war. Und als er dann zurückkam, hat er in fast jedem Spiel getroffen. Also bei seiner Rückkehr nach Wadenverletzung direkt im 1. Spiel 2 Tore, im nächsten Spiel 1 Tor, 2 Vorlagen. Im Spiel darauf wieder 2 Tore. Dann fehlt er wegen einer Gelbsperre. Dann kam er zurück von der Gelbsperre, direkt wieder ein Tor geschossen. Und sie haben diese Spiele fast alle gewonnen bzw. unentschieden. Also Iago Aspas hat wirklich Single-Handed, wie man im Englischen so schon sagt, hat Celta Vigo gerettet in dieser Saison. Ohne den wären die abgestiegen definitiv.
Was erschreit denn der Spanier, wenn der Fußballgott an einen Iago Aspas anhängt?
Also der Fußballgott wird natürlich vor allem in Deutschland fast schon zu inflationär benutzt. In Spanien hat das nochmal eine ganz andere Bedeutung. Als Aspas beispielsweise von der Wadenverletzung zurückkam, war er dann sichtlich nicht fit. Das hat man wirklich gesehen, dass sie ihn quasi fast schon zu früh zurückgebracht haben, weil sie so abhängig von ihm waren. Als er die Tore schoss, ist er wirklich zusammengebrochen, am Spielfeld und hat geweint. Da hat man auch gemerkt, wie sehr ihm der Verein was bedeutet, wie sehr ihm die Situation nahegeht. Er hat auch in Interviews nach dem Spiel gesagt, dass die Leute gar nicht wissen, was das für mich bedeutet. Das kann man gar nicht in Worte fassen. Also er ist tatsächlich so verbunden mit dem Verein und der Verein mit ihm und logischerweise dann auch die Anhänger. Das ist eine richtig, richtig krasse Story in Spanien. Und wird natürlich leider nicht so wahrgenommen, weil logischerweise im Blickfeld der Medien ist immer wieder Barca und Messi und Real, das Chaos bei Real und Atletico dann auch. Aber tatsächlich ist das vielleicht die besonders Geschichte in Spanien. Es ist Yago Aspas und Celta Vigo und die Rettung. Also wirklich eine tolle Geschichte, was man echt sagen kann.
Und wenn dann die eine Mannschaft über ihre Rettung schöne Geschichten schreiben kann, haben wir mit FC Girona einen Absteiger, der auch eine bemerkenswerte Saison hinter sich hat. Und da kann man eigentlich auch den größeren Bogen spannen. In der letzten Saison als Aufsteiger auf Tabellenplatz 10 gelandet, war eine der positiven Überraschungen der Liga. Und wenn man sich jetzt einfach nur das Endergebnis anguckt, dann denkt man sich, naja, gut, das ist halt das verflickste zweite Jahr. Da muss man eben einfach runter. Das ist halt alles nicht so schlimm. Aber dann gucken wir mal kurz auf den Saisonverlauf. Und wir sehen in der Hinrundentabelle Chirona auf Platz 9 mit Anschluss an die internationalen Plätze. In der Rückrundentabelle vorletzt dann nur noch 13 Punkte geholt, 14 Mal verloren in den letzten 19 Spielen. Und so musste man jetzt dann absteigen. Kann man festmachen, was da passiert ist, dass diese Rückrunde so katastrophal war, dass sie dann aus dem absoluten gesicherten Tabellenbereich bis in den Abstieg runterführt?
Also Girona ist das Beispiel für den Negativstrudeln. Wir hatten diese positive Hinrunde bei Valencia und Bilbao mit einer positiven Rückrunde. Bei Girona war es genau andersrum. Wir haben eigentlich eine gute Hinrunde gespielt. Am 19. Spieltag waren wir noch neunter. Sie ist auch da wieder überperformt. Eigentlich eine gute Mannschaft, ein gutes Team. Ab dann ging es immer mehr abwärts Spiel um Spiel verloren. Sie konnten überhaupt nicht mehr gewinnen. Sie hatten eine schlechte Heimbilanz. Nur 3 Heimsiege im 19. Spiel. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher. Ich müsste nachgucken. Seit September konnten sie nicht mehr daheim gewinnen. Das ist völlig unerklärlich. Vor allem zu Hause. Gerade kleine Mannschaften sind oft eher auswärts schwach. Sie holen dann aber daheim ihre Punkte. Bei Girona war es andersrum. Sie konnten plötzlich zu Hause nicht mehr gewinnen. Sie kamen dann in eine Negativspirale. Auch sie haben versucht, am Trainer festzuhalten. Das sollte sich nicht bezahlbar machen. Im Nachhinein werden sie es wahrscheinlich bereuen. Hätten sie mal lieber reagiert. Im Nachhinein ist man immer schlauer.
Jetzt wollen wir Vereine nicht dafür taten, dass sie an ihrem Trainer festhalten. Aber es war eine bemerkenswerte Saison. Der letzte Heimsieg war Ende Oktober. In den Spielen von Girona hatte ich immer wieder Spiele, wo man sich gedacht hat, jetzt haben sie sich gefangen. Gegen Atletico und 1 zu 1 geholt, das war noch in der Hinrunde. Gegen Barca, zwar 0 zu 2 verloren im Heimspiel, aber da hat sich Barca gar nicht so leicht getan. Auswärts, Bayern, Madrid gewonnen. Man möchte ketscherisch sagen, wer hat das nicht. Das war damals in der Phase, in der man vier Unentschieden in Serie hatte und aus den letzten neun Spielen nur drei Unentschieden und sechs Niederlagen geholt hat. Man hatte das Gefühl, das könnte der Umschwung gewesen sein. Das war es dann auch gegen Sociedad, gegen Vallecano unentschieden und gewonnen. Unglückliche Niederlage gegen Valencia natürlich wieder zu Hause. Dann war es das aber auch schon mit den positiven Erlebnissen. Noch einmal gegen Leganes gewonnen am 28. Spieltag, noch einmal gegen den FC Sevilla zu Hause gewonnen. Das FC Sevilla-Segment haben wir ja auch schon ein bisschen thematisiert, dass da bei denen ein bisschen was verloren ging.
Tatsächlich, da haben sie es dann gewonnen. Da war es fast schon zu spät dann.
Genau. Sie waren schon in diesem Strudel. Das waren immer so knappe Niederlagen. 1 zu 2, 0 zu 1, 1 zu 2, 0 zu 1. Ja, da war auch mal 0 zu 2 mit dabei. Aber so von meiner Sicht, die ich auf Girona hatte, war es einfach ein sehr unnötiger Abstieg, weil du gleichzeitig zwar die Aufholjagd von Celta Vigo hattest, aber die war ja auch alles andere als felsenfest. Die haben wir ja gerade rausgearbeitet, auch sehr an einem Spieler. Also ein Abstieg, der zwar nicht völlig überraschend ist, wenn ein Aufsteiger aus dem Vorjahr in seine zweite Saison geht, aber von außen betrachtet auf mich völlig unnötig wirkt.
Ja, da gebe ich dir voll recht. Tatsächlich auch für mich völlig unnötig, auch unerwartet. Ich fand sie auch eigentlich immer wirklich gut genug, um in der Liga zu bleiben. Ich hätte immer gesagt, zwischen Platz 10 und 14 wäre das völlig normal, wenn sie da landen. Und da haben sie, meiner Meinung nach, auch das Potenzial und die Stärke dafür gehabt. Ein völlig unnötiger Abstieg. Sie haben vom 29. bis 34. Spieltag, glaube ich, sechs Niederlagen am Stück kassiert. Da hätte man vielleicht sagen können, vielleicht – also nochmal, ich bin keiner, der Trainerentlassung fordert oder gut findet – aber aus Sicht des Vereins, vielleicht hätten sie da wirklich die Reißleine ziehen müssen, um da nochmal frischen Wind zu kriegen. Denn in den letzten zehn Spielen haben sie einfach neunmal verloren. Mit der Ausnahme Heimsic Sevilla, die du genannt hast. Also du siehst, das ist dann einfach hinten raus völlig schief gegangen. Wirklich, wirklich schwer zu erklären. Nackter Blick auf die Zahlen sagt, okay, zu wenig Tore geschossen, nur 37 Tore in 30 Spielen, gleichzeitig zu viele Tore kassiert, 53. Zur Wahrheit gehört wirklich, dass sie abwärts zu instabil war und vorne hatten sie einen einzigen Spieler, der Tore garantiert hat, Christian Stoani, 19 Saisontore, muss man sich mal vorstellen, für den Absteiger. Richtig klasse Ausbeute.
Und dann haben wir ja aber bei Girona noch diese Besonderheit, dass man so eine Art Farmteam von Manchester City ist. Also man hat sehr, sehr viele Leihspiele immer von City in seinen Reihen. Und deswegen ist es jetzt auch nicht der klassischste aller Aufsteiger gewesen. Das gehört zu dieser Geschichte eben auch noch mit dazu. Ich habe das jetzt aber dann in diesem Jahr nicht mehr so wirklich verfolgt. Im vorherigen Jahr hatte man noch fünf Spieler, die man ausgeliehen hat zur neuen Saison hin von Manchester City. Jetzt in dieser Saison war es nur noch ein Spieler. Hat sich da was am Verhältnis zu City verändert? Sind die anderen Spieler einfach noch mit in die neue Saison gegangen? Kannst du uns noch kurz erklären, ob es diese Beziehung zwischen den beiden Vereinen so noch gibt?
Also generell etwas schwer zu sagen, weil City, also Girona ist ja quasi so eine Tochter der City Group, glaube ich, da natürlich auch nicht will, dass man da alles rausbekommt, logischerweise.
City ist nicht völlig transparent? Das sind ja Zustände in der Liga, also das ist ja Wahnsinn.
Tatsächlich wird es für die Men's City Group keine gute… Die werden nicht erfreut sein über den Abstieg. Klar, die wollten hier so ein bisschen das Farmteam etablieren und für die ist das ein Schlagenkontor, dass ihr Farmteam, wenn man so will, auch wenn es dieses Jahr eben nicht mehr so deutlich war, aber dass die abgestiegen sind, ist natürlich für Manchester City und für die Scheichs schlechte News. Vielleicht für die Fußballpuristen, die sind dann nicht ganz so traurig darüber, könnte man jetzt auch sagen, die Romantiker, die sowas…
Das wäre jetzt mal eine Anschlussfrage gewesen. Wird Girona dann auch sehr kritisch gesehen von den Fans in der spanischen Liga?
Generell ist auch, da die Spanier sind da nicht so… Der Deutsche ist kulturell bedingt, glaube ich, da eher stört sich eher an so Gebilden. Der Spanier ist da, glaube ich, nicht ganz so berührt davon. Da gibt es Proteste oder so was wie in Deutschland, wo man sich da vorstellt, wie die BVB-Fans gegen Hoffenheim oder gegen Leipzig reagieren. So etwas gibt es in Spanien gar nicht. Es wird nicht so hochgehängt. Die sehen das generell einfach entspannter und lockerer, muss man nicht sagen. Ob das gut ist oder schlecht, will ich jetzt überhaupt nicht bewerten. Die Kultur ist einfach ein bisschen anders.
Es ist einfach ein bisschen anders. Alex, wir haben es tatsächlich geschafft, diese Liga zu besprechen. Leider konnten wir jetzt nicht jeden, vor allem mit ein paar Worten, bedachten. Seht es uns nach, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und dir ganz herzlichen Dank, dass du dir trotz aller technischen Probleme und einem weit, weit verspäteten Anpfiff hier für unsere Sendung die Zeit genommen hast für den Rasenfunk. Wenn sich die Hörerinnen und Hörer jetzt da draußen denken, was, technische Probleme? Dann ist alles gut gegangen mit der Backup-Aufnahme. Und solltet ihr es aber auch gehört haben, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dann möchte ich mich an der Stelle entschuldigen. Wir haben sämtliche Register gezogen. Es ist heute ein verhexter Tag für den Rasenfunk aus audiotechnischer Sicht. Aber dank so geduldiger Gäste wie Alex Truica ist es dann inhaltlich trotzdem ein guter Tag geworden. Und hoffentlich konntet ihr alles auch in einer annehmbaren Soundqualität hören. Alex, ich danke dir sehr, dass du mit dabei warst.
Vielen Dank, Max. Es war mir wie immer eine Ehre und Freude. Hat großen Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich trotz aller Probleme, die wirklich so zahlreich heute waren. Ich möchte gar nicht anfangen. Also Alex Truica, ihr könnt ihm auf Twitter folgen. Da heißt er praktischerweise auch genauso wie im echten Leben. Alex Truica, er schreibt bei Barcawelt, er ist freier Sportjournalist. Und wie ihr eben hören konntet, einer der besten Experten, wenn es um die spanische Liga geht im deutschsprachigen Raum. Danke dir, Alex. Und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Mal gucken, ob es noch weitere internationale Kurzpässe geben wird. Dadurch, dass sich jetzt einige Dinge grad terminlich verschieben mit dieser etwas verpatzten Aufnahme zeitlich gesehen. Weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr, ob ich da in der nächsten Woche noch was drauflegen kann, denn es läuft ja gerade die Aufzeichnung für den Rasenfunk Royale. Der kommt aber auf jeden Fall Ende Mai. Macht es gut, bis dahin eine gute Zeit.